um yeah so i
am playing uh against alan
pisho or that's how you would pronounce
it
in french i suppose don't know how you
pronounce it in
argentinian just kidding i know of
course the people speak
spanish in argentina anyway
i think he won the
world under 16 championship a few years
ago
it's now a very strong ground master
now that he's grown up a little bit i
think 2600 something
so he played the world cup earlier this
september
and now he's got e4 i'm go c5
just for fun knight c6
playing my reporter let's see what he's
got
probably doesn't think that i'm going to
use all my novelties
in the banter blitz cup in that case i
would say
think again of course i'm going to play
my best
stuff i want to win this thing
that's castle
and rook v8 this is what i always do
g3
but that's not supposed to be too
critical now i get
bit the bishop away now i can play 97
later on
guess i should go a5 first just to
prevent
the knight from coming to b4
and now i will soon have some decent
control over the d5 square
and thus i should
be completely out of trouble
although obviously she's um
very very solid so i can't
think of uh an advantage yet but
i'm absolutely fine she should be a bit
careful here
seeing that there are some motifs
uh connected with the with
the uh the long diagonal
like let's say if it takes you might
already be in
some trouble you should probably sack
the queen here
otherwise i get this
i don't know if queen c6 first or
[Music]
but i feel like already forcing f3 is a
big deal
yeah probably rook d8 first then i'll go
queen c6 next and force f3
what am i talking about he can go king
h2
that's ridiculous but i'm still a bit
better with this
battery and control over the d file
but yeah it was indeed a bit sloppy
should i go with g6 i don't love g6 but
i gotta maybe i'll go
yeah let's go g6 i didn't really like
any of the ways of uh
defending um
okay i'm playing so sloppily here
now he uh he's exploiting some
some opportunities that i'm giving him
so
that was unnecessary
i'm still a bit better but not much
like for instance if he takes he should
make it wrong
yeah attacks on d2 i'll be upon
up in the ending but i don't think it
would be enough
i'll try and flag him maybe i don't know
how fast he is
okay no worries
for those who watched our live broadcast
of the
with the world cup earlier uh
earlier this week
vichygov actually uh lost
this particular ending to uh to yu yang
yi
which goes to show that although
this three versus two is drawn it's
it's not completely easy
and i'm gonna try for a while rook a6
now he's really playing with fire
okay let me check
check again okay let's just
king h3 oh rook f6 now he's lost
yeah apparently his endings are not his
uh
strongest suit now i'm winning the other
pawn and
it's easily winning check check the pawn
the other one runs and that's the game
okay good stuff